empecemos hablando de macrón envía hoy
un mensaje de unión junto a sus
homólogos de alemania y polonia en ese
sentido se puede decir que fue un error
ir ayer a moscú no no no no ha sido un
error manuel mantiene una relación
privilegiada con putin ya se habían
encontrado varias veces piensa que puede
lograr un gesto concreto por parte del
presidente ruso aunque la política
exterior de majón puede parecer un
poquito inocente mccomb piensa que ahí
puede imponer un poquito su leadership
natural de francia para lograr un
acuerdo en esta crisis y obviamente así
ganar visibilidad tanto en la escena
internacional como marcar puntos también
en la política interior francesa y usted
menciona precisamente la política
interior francesa se podría decir
entonces que el recorrido de macrón
podría tener motivos para mover su o en
el año electoral de francia en este
momento claro que si podemos decir que
el activismo diplomático de mayo se usa
como un arma digamos de política
interior que va a servir para pulsar su
candidatura a su propia reelección que
tendrá lugar el 10 de abril y también
permite a makoun dar una dimensión
internacional a su candidatura e
imponerse frente a sus contricantes
franceses que no gozan digamos de stay
leadership natural que tiene bajo en la
escena internacional no olvidemos que
francia tiene la presidencia desde el
primero de enero de la unión europea
entonces más con quiera aprovechar este
espacio internacional también para
reafirmar su liderazgo dentro de las
encuestas para la elección del próximo
creciente ya propósito este espacio
internacional que usted menciona como
ayuda en estas giras a la posición de
francia en el mundo
bueno makoun quiere imponerse como el
líder ahora el gran líder de la unión
europea no olvidemos entonces que angela
markel ya salió
franco-alemán era como el motor de la
unión europea ahora mccomb es el que
queda es la figura más visible digamos
del líder a nivel de la unión europea
entonces intenta aprovechar esta crisis
ucraniana para reforzar digamos la idea
de que francia es el un uno de los
países motores de la unión europea y que
aquí tiene una posición de autoridad y
de liderazgo privilegiado para resolver
este tipo de crisis y proyectar el país
como un líder natural en el espacio
europeo